und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend zur
ersten heute journalsendung im Jahr 2022
noch wünscht man sich ja Rai um ein
frohes neues Jahr und fragt sich dabei
aber schon wie froh ist tatsächlich
werden wird im letzten Jahr hofften die
meisten dass es das Jahr der Impfungen
wird wie kamen dann ja auch aber dann
kam leider auch Omicron und wie wird
dieses Jahr werden wir erleben dass das
Leben wieder normal wird die Pandemie
ausläuft einiges spricht dafür aber bis
dahin wird noch ein Tal zu durchqueren
sein in den Kliniken schaut man
jedenfalls mit Sorge auf die nächsten
Wochen Verena Garrett berichtet
wenn es doch noch mal hart auf hart
kommen sollte haben Sie hier Platz für
24 kurve-patienten zurzeit sind es fünf
im corona-beatmungszentrum im Klinikum
Saarbrücken haben sie schwere Zeiten
hinter sich und wissen nicht genau was
sie im neuen Jahr mit ommikron erwartet
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass wieder
mehr Patienten kommen wie viele sein
werden das ist schwer abzuschätzen aber
ich denke es wird noch eine Zeit lang
hier weitergehen weniger Patienten auf
Intensiv das heißt nachholen was sie
aufgrund von zu vielen schwer
corona-erkrankten nicht leisten konnten
Krebs und Schmerzpatienten verschobene
routine-ops das muss schnell
aufgearbeitet werden denn hier ahnen sie
die gemeldeten Zahlen in Deutschland
sind unvollständig sie steigen nur
langsam und doch prognostizieren
Modellierer einen Anstieg wie eine Wand
die Zahlen aktuell dürften dem aktuellen
Infektionsgeschehen hinterherhinken
deswegen gehe ich davon aus dass wir
hier im neuen Jahr relativ eine starke
Anstiege sehen können das hängt
natürlich immer und das muss man immer
den Konjunktiv verwenden weil es hängt
sehr stark davon ab wie wir uns
verhalten das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
das hängt an uns an uns Menschen wie die
Bevölkerung sich verhält Schulferien
Weihnachtstage in den letzten Wochen
würde weniger getestet und um genau zu
wissen mit welcher Variante ein Mensch
infiziert ist muss die positive Probe
nochmal genetisch untersucht das heißt
sequenziert werden das braucht Zeit
zudem waren zwischen den Jahren viele
Gesundheitsämter gar nicht oder nur dünn
besetzt es kann nicht sein dass die
Daten von den Gesundheitsämtern nicht
ins RKI übermittelt werden oder von den
Laboren über die Gesundheitsämter ins
RKI nicht zeitgemäß übermittelt werden
wir leben in einem hochtechnologisierten
Land und es ist schon eigentlich ein
gewisse Tragik dass das ganze nicht
vernünftig funktioniert auffallend viele
ommikron-fälle gibt es im Norden
Deutschlands die Sozialbehörde in
Hamburg geht davon aus dass in der
Hansestadt etwa zehn Prozent der
Infektionen auf die Variante zurückgehen
und dass sich der Anteil innerhalb einer
Woche mindestens verdoppelt das liegt
einerseits daran dass hier viel
sequenziert wird also auch mehr als im
restlichen Bundesgebiet werden hier
proben daraufhin untersucht zu welcher
virus-variante sie gehören gleichzeitig
ist aber auch nicht von der Hand zu
weisen dass ein regionalen Einfluss gibt
die Nähe zur europäischen Nachbarländern
die stärker von Omegon betroffen sind
das impftempo soll weiter erhöht werden
denn auch wenn es inzwischen Hinweise
darauf gibt dass Omicron etwas weniger
schwerer Erkrankungen verursacht als
bisherige pandemiewellen eine Entwarnung
für ungeimpfte sei das nicht sagt der
Bundesgesundheitsminister bei den
ungeimpften müssen wir leider mit
schweren Verläufen rechnen und daher ist
also unser Schwerpunkt jetzt den
ungeimpften zu helfen ich appelliere an
alle ungeimpfen wenigstens diese erste
Impfung zu machen denn damit also
reduziert man das Risiko sehr schwer zu
erkranken oder gar zu versterben doch
schon deutlich im Klinikum Saarbrücken
haben sie die Hoffnungen dass die große
Flut ankurved-patienten auf der inten
Situation in der fünften Welle ausbleibt
vorbereitet darauf aber sind sie
die Bundesregierung schließt im Moment
jedenfalls nichts aus ob Impfpflicht
oder zusätzliche kontaktbeschränkungen
das wird wohl auch davon abhängen wie
sich die Lage entwickelt und das dürfte
auch zu weiteren Debatten führen über
die Einschränkung von Freiheitsrechten
Ende November hatte das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ja die im
Frühjahr verhängte sogenannte
bundesnotbremse nachträglich abgesegnet
anders als die Kläger erhofft hatten der
Politik wurde von Karlsruhe einen
relativ weiter Entscheidungsspielraum
gewährt es gibt nur selten die
Gelegenheit darüber mit einem aktiven
Mitglied des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
öffentlich zu sprechen die Karlsruher
Richter und Richterinnen geben in der
Regel keine Interviews sondern sprechen
wie es so schön heißt durch ihre Urteile
doch heute haben wir die Gelegenheit mit
bundesverfassungsrichtern Henning Radtke
der maßgeblich an der Entscheidung zur
bundesnotbremse beteiligt war guten
Abend Herr Professor Radtke
guten Abend Frau Slomka ich wünsche
Ihnen ein gutes neues Jahr das wünsche
ich Ihnen auch und wir wollen auch
direkt in dieses neue Jahr schauen da
ist ja noch vieles unsicher eine
pandemischen Lage aber es ist ja denkbar
dass es wieder neue Maßnahmen gibt oder
darüber diskutiert wird zusätzliche das
was der Volksmund Lockdown womöglich
nennt was können denn die Politiker die
Regierenden aus den bisherigen
Entscheidungen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts auf der
juristischen Seite dazu lernen ich
glaube zwei Dinge sind ganz wichtig zu
betonen das erste auch in der Pandemie
gelten die Grundrechte in vollem Umfang
und das zweite wenn Grundrechte
eingeschränkt werden um der Pandemie
Herr zu werden dann geht das nur unter
den allgemeinen Voraussetzungen jeder
anderen
grundrechtseinschränkung auch und das
ist im Wesentlichen der Grundsatz der
Verhältnismäßigkeit der dabei zu
berücksichtigen ist und das wird die
Politik auch in Zukunft zu
berücksichtigen haben hat sich denn mit
Blick darauf dass es mittlerweile ja
Impfungen in größeren Maße gibt als das
jetzt im Frühjahr letzten Jahres der
Fall war hat sich da die der Maßstab der
Verhältnismäßigkeit geändert
der Maßstab der Verhältnismäßigkeit
bleibt immer gleich er besteht aus einem
vierklang der Gesetzgeber muss legitime
Ziele verfolgen die Maßnahmen die er
einsetzten müssen geeignet sein um diese
Ziele zu erreichen sie müssen
erforderlich sein dürfen also nicht
darüber hinausgehen und am Ende muss das
Ganze auch noch angemessen also
verhältnismäßig im engen Sinne sein das
ist eine Abwägung zwischen dem
Betroffenen Grundrechten einerseits und
den zu schützenden rechten andererseits
und diese Maßstäbe sind insoweit zeitlos
nicht zeitlos ist ihre Anwendung auf die
konkreten Maßnahmen um die es geht die
sind durchaus von den jeweiligen
Verhältnissen abhängig wie ist der im
Fortschritt welche Wirkungen haben die
Impfungen das muss dann wiederum Politik
einschätzen sich aber daran orientieren
was die Verhältnismäßigkeit ihnen
vorgibt nun gab es ja diese Entscheidung
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts vom 30
Jahr 30 November zur sogenannten
bundesnotbrem man halt auch sehr viel
Kritik ausgelöst wie Sie wissen da wurde
auch gesagt das Verfassungsgericht hat
er eigentlich keine klaren Leitlinien
gegeben sogar von einer
verfassungsrechtlichen Abstinenz war die
Rede der Entscheidungsspielraum für die
Politik sei viel zu groß gewesen oder um
es jetzt mal ganz salopp zu sagen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hätte sich da
einen schlanken Fuß gemacht
ich kann Kritik gut verstehen wenn es
darum geht es viele Menschen in diesem
Lande Sorge haben um ihre Freiheitsrecht
und Kritik am Bundesverfassungsgericht
gehört dazu wie Kritik auch an allen
anderen Verfassungsorganen geübt wird in
der Sache kann ich diese Kritik
allerdings nicht teilen und ich kann
Anknüpfen an das was ich eben gesagt
habe wir haben in diesen beiden
Entscheidungen zur bundesnotbremse die
verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsätze so
angewendet wie sie der ständigen
Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts entsprechen
und was dort an Spielräumen eröffnet
worden ist sind die Spielräume die der
demokratisch unmittelbar legitimierte
Gesetzgeber eben hat in der Pandemie wie
außerhalb der Pandemie und insoweit wie
gesagt vermag ich diese Kritik in der
Sache nicht zu teilen aber das Gericht
nimmt jede Kritik auf verarbeitet sie
und versucht konstruktiv für die
nächsten Entscheidungen damit umzugehen
entschieden wohl bei vielen der Eindruck
dass man jetzt danach eigentlich so
schlau ist als wie zuvor also es bleibt
dann der Politik zu überlassen
Grundrechte einzuschränken und das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat keine
klaren Vorgaben gemacht weshalb dann zum
Teil auch auch
oberlandesverwaltungsgerichte ihre
eigenen Entscheidungen treffen also so
als der normale Bürgerin weiß man nicht
so recht was ist denn nun eigentlich
verhältnismäßig gerade auch mit Blick
auf auf die nächsten Entscheidungen die
womöglich anstehen zu Schulschließungen
etwa zu ausgangsbeeren
doch ich glaube schon dass man sehr
genau vorhersehen kann was die
Verhältnismäßigkeit auch für zukünftige
Maßnahmen bedeutet nehmen wir das
Beispiel
ausgangsbeschränkungen
ausgangsbeschränkungen sind in den von
uns zu überprüfen denn gesetzlichen
Regelungen zur bundesnotbremse ein
Mittel gewesen um das eigentliche
relevante nämlich kontaktbeschränkungen
zu fördern zu stärken und jetzt ist
einfach unter
verhältnismäßigkeitsgesichtspunkten zu
erwägen bedarf es
ausgangsbeschränkungen um effektiv
kontaktbeschränkungen durchsetzen zu
können weil die kontaktbeschränkungen
das Mittel sind dass die Ausbreitung des
Virus effektiv bekämpfen kann das ist
das entscheidende
sagt bundesverfassungsrecht dahin sehr
für das Gespräch
ich danke herzlich für die Gelegenheit
im Namen des Gerichts
das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen aufgezeichnet das Deutschland
pandemisch gerade ziemlich im
nebelstochert könnte zu einem bösen
Erwachen führen wenn es wieder aktuelle
Zahlen gibt andere Länder kennen solche
feiertagspausen übrigens nicht Beispiel
Dänemark dass die denen im September
beschlossen mit Corona sei es weitgehend
vorbei war wahrscheinlich keine gute
Idee als Omicron kam breitete es sich
dort besonders schnell aus ähnlich wie
in Großbritannien aber die Dänen haben
zumindest einen klaren Blick auf die
epidemische Lage in ihrem Land Henna
Hebestreit zeigt was dort anders läuft
als bei uns
grün ist die Farbe der Hoffnung und
deshalb starten Sie auch in Dänemark mit
Blumen zuversichtlich ins neue Jahr
dabei hat das Coronavirus Dänemark
gerade besonders fest im Griff im
staatlichen gesundheitsinstitut haben
sie trotz der Feiertage die Lage in
Echtzeit im Blick die landesweite
Inzidenz liegt heute bei
1.866,9
eine Zunahme der Infektionen und
gleichzeitig müssen mehr Menschen ins
Krankenhaus und auf die
Intensivstationen aber der Anstieg ist
nicht so drastisch wie die Zunahme der
Infektionen
bei der zentralen Gesundheitsbehörde
laufen die Daten aus den Krankenhäusern
Impfzentren und teslabors rund um die
Uhr ein Dänemarks Gesundheitssystem ist
hochgradig digitalisiert und so weiß man
hier dass der Anteil von Omegon schon
jetzt bei 80% der nachgewiesenen
Infektionen liegt während man den
anderen Ländern noch auf genauere Zahlen
wartet
jetzt vor die
ich glaube Deutschland liegt was unikron
Infektionen angeht schon fast gleich auf
mit Dänemark ich meine ganz Europa
erlebt einen markanten Anstieg der
infektionskurve weil Omikron im größten
Teil Europas bereits dominiert
Vermutungen belegt ist das noch nicht
trotzdem wird Dänemark für den Rest
Europas zum Labor wie man trotz hoher
Infektionszahlen die kritische
Infrastruktur wie zum Beispiel
Eisenbahnen am Laufen hält bislang
verzichtet die Regierung auf strikte
kontaktbeschränkungen lockert sogar die
quarantäne-regelungen ich glaube man ist
trying to see how much infection die
Regierung versucht herauszufinden wie
viele Infektionen die Gesellschaft
ertragen kann ohne das Gesundheitssystem
zu überlassen das führt zu Diskussionen
in der Bevölkerung ob wir mehr Maßnahmen
brauchen oder gar keine weil es in der
Natur der Sache liegt dass wir uns alle
irgendwann anstecken
Dänemark sieht sich gerüstet für dieses
Experiment knapp 78% der über
zwölfjährigen sind doppelt geimpft und
das impftempo bleibt hoch auch in den
Apotheken in der Bevölkerung sind
strenge Einschränkungen wenig populär
na ja ich habe das schon selbst erlebt
kurz vor Weihnachten das war nicht so
schlimm ich bin der geimpft ich hatte
keine Angst
ich finde es hat so viele Schließungen
gegeben wir sind doch in der Lage und
selbst vernünftig zu schützen
so ganz will sich die Regierung darauf
nicht verlassen so mussten sich zum
Beispiel die Rekruten der königlichen
Garde über die Festtage in der Kaserne
isolieren damit Omikron den Schutz der
Königsfamilie nicht gefährdet
und jetzt macht erstmal Hans Wolf weiter
mit den Nachrichten
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner hat den
Aussicht gestellt dass in dieser
Legislaturperiode die Menschen und der
Mittelstand um mehr als 30 Milliarden
Euro entlastet werden in der Bild am
Sonntag nannte Lindner konkrete
Beispiele aus dem Koalitionsvertrag etwa
das Steuerzahler die Beiträge für die
Rentenversicherung künftig voll absetzen
können Lob dafür kommt vom
mittelstandsverband die Linke dagegen
spricht von einer Umverteilung von unten
nach oben
die EU hat mit ihrem Vorstoß zur
Einstufung von Atomkraft als grüne
Energiequelle teils heftige Reaktionen
ausgelöst Österreichs
klimaschutzministerin Gewässer drohte
mit einer Klage vor dem Europäischen
Gerichtshof wenn die Pläne umgesetzt
würden auch von deutschen
Regierungsmitgliedern kam Widerspruch
der Kommissionsentwurf sieht vor dass
Investitionen in Atom- und
Gaskraftwerken unter bestimmten
Bedingungen als nachhaltig eingestuft
werden können
Nordrhein-Westfalens Innenminister Royal
hat die Schändung muslimische Gräber in
Iserlohn als abscheuliches Verbrechen
verurteilt in jeder Religion sei die
Toten Ruhe heilig unbekannte hatten
vermutlich zwischen Freitag Mittag und
Neujahrs morgen auf einem Friedhof in
Iserlohn rund 30 muslimische Grabsteine
geschändet am Nachmittag kamen hunderte
Menschen zusammen um Solidarität mit den
Angehörigen der Toten zu zeigen und ein
Zeichen für religiöse Toleranz zu setzen
Ukraine Konflikt will US-Präsident
beiden nach dem Telefonat mit
russlandspräsident Putin am Donnerstag
heute Abend mit dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selensky telefonisch über
die Situation beraten nach Angaben aus
Washington solle es dabei auch um
diplomatische Bemühungen für eine
Deeskalation gehen hintergrund ist ein
Aufmarsch russischer Truppen nahe der
ukrainischen Grenze
ein Großbrand hat dann Gebäuden des
südafrikanischen Parlaments sind
Kapstadt schwere Schäden angerichtet das
Feuer auf dem Gelände war am frühen
Morgen ausgebrochen dutzende
Feuerwehrleute kämpften gegen die
Flammen ein Dach ist eingestürzt das
Gebäude der Nationalversammlung wurde
komplett zerstört verletzt wurde bislang
offenbar niemand warum das Feuer
ausbrach ist noch unklar
vor 20 Jahren konnte man sich in diesen
Neujahrstagen sein Starterkit abholen
ein Tütchen Münzen Euro Münzen seitdem
ist eine ganze Generation herangewachsen
die gar keine andere heimische Währung
mehr kennt die milde lächelt wenn ältere
sich nostalgisch erinnern wie hübsch die
50 pfennig-münze aussah und die sich
auch schwerlich vorstellen kann wie
unser eins anfangs noch in D-Mark
umrechnete um Preise fühlen zu können es
soll Leute geben die das immer noch tun
aber das dürfte wohl nur noch eine
Minderheit sein zum Jubiläum schaut
Isabel de la Vega zurück aber auch nach
vorn auf die aktuellen Herausforderungen
für Europas gemeinsame Währung
eine mini-ausstellung würde ich derzeit
in Frankfurt am Main den 20 Geburtstag
des Euro und für sprachlich stets
zurückhaltende Bundesbanker sind solche
Glückwünsche gerade zu euphorisch wir
sehen hier wie schön frisch jung und vor
allem stark der Euro ist und wie auch
immer sein wird der erste erste 200
2 war Geldes eine Welle der Begeisterung
ergreift viele Bundesbürger findest toll
fühlt sich gut an haben wir so
aufgewartet zwei eins einen Run auf die
ersten Euro hatte es schon ein paar Tage
zuvor gegeben bei der Ausgabe der
sogenannten Starterkits nachts
stundenlanges Warten vor den
geldschaltern jeder will die
pressfrischen Münzen einmal in den
Händen halten
es ist was einmaliges so das Geld
umzuwechseln ist ganz toll bye bye
D-Mark Symbol für Demokratie und
Wohlstand der Abschied fällt nicht jedem
leicht
die junge Generation ist begeistert die
mittlere Generation noch eher skeptisch
und in der älteren überwiegen auch
Ablehnung ich bin glücklich zwei Monate
lang werden beide Währungen in den Läden
akzeptiert und das Land liegt im
rechenfieber
1,95583 D-Mark sind ein Euro manche
Händler Runden auf und der Euro gilt
bald als teurer
rot und Brötchen die sind ja misste 20
Prozent teurer doch über die Jahre
gesehen lag die Teuerungsrate beim Euro
sehr niedrig bei durchschnittlich 1,4
Prozent die große bewehrungsprobe für
die Gemeinschaftswährung Naht mit der
Finanz- und Schuldenkrise 2008 Italien
Irland und Griechenland Straucheln und
die Gefahr dass diese Staaten den Euro
verlassen könnten
ängstlich die Politik
scheitert der Euro dann scheitert Europa
als Rettungsmaßnahmen senkt die EZB den
Leitzins bis auf null Prozent und kauft
massiv Anleihen auch hochverschuldeter
Eurostaaten die entscheidenden Worte des
izb-chefs
die EZB wird alles tun um den Euro zu
bewahren
jetzt in der corona-krise ist die
Inflation gestiegen und die EZB steckt
in einem Dilemma Ursache für die
Inflation ist jetzt nicht der Euro aber
die hohen staatsschuldenstände machen es
natürlich schwierig für die EZB die
Zinsen anzuheben um die Inflation zu
begrenzen wichtig ist es dass die EZB
sich dadurch nicht einschüchtern lässt
sondern sie muss rechtzeitig genug auf
die Bremse treten auf die Bremse treten
und die Zinsen wieder anheben diese
Wände bleibt bislang allerdings noch aus
und so wird der Euro in seinem
Jubiläumsjahr im Zeichen der Inflation
stehen
und noch mal heizt mit dem Sport an
diesem Wochenende und zuerst zum Tennis
da gab es eine Niederlage für das
deutsche Team beim ATP Cup die
nachfolgewettbewerb des Tennis Davis Cup
1 zu 2 stand es am Ende in Sydney gegen
Großbritannien den Punkt für die
deutsche Auswahl holte Alexander Zverev
im Einzel gegen Cameron Nori
im ersten Match nach sechs Wochen Pause
tat sich sverev zunächst schwer gegen
die Nummer 12 der Weltrangliste Cameron
norri im Vordergrund jagte Deutschland
Sportler des Jahres über den Platz hatte
einen satzbeil und lag vorn bis zu
diesem herrlichen Ballwechsel mit
zverevs Stop und volley zum fünf zu fünf
danach holte der Brite nur noch zwei
Spiele und zverevlich mit dem sieben zu
sechs und sechs zu eins zum 11 für
Deutschland aus musste aber auch zum
Doppel an der Seite von Kevin Krawitz
antreten weil sich dessen stammpartner
Tim Pütz verletzt hatte leichte Fehler
führten zur schnellen 3:6 4:6 Niederlage
gegen Daniel Evans Jamie Marie und dem
eins zu zwei gegen Großbritannien nun
muss Deutschland Dienstag gegen die USA
gewinnen
und zum Wintersport da meldete sich
heute im Zweierbob nach einem
enttäuschenden zwölften Platz im Weltcup
gestern Pilot Francesco Friedrich zurück
im lettischen sekundar entschied sich
der Doppel Olympiasieger heute für ein
Schieber Torsten magis und feierte auch
Danke an der konzentrierteren
Fahrleistung seinen insgesamt 63
weltcupsieg
beim Rodel Weltcup in Winterberg krönte
Julia taubitz heute ein ohnehin schon
erfolgreiches Wochenende für die
deutschen Rennrodler die Weltmeisterin
setzte sich in einem spannenden Rennen
vor Olympia Siegerin natalie
Geisenberger durch und fuhr zu einem
vierten Saisonsieg im starken zweiten
Lauf verbesserte sich taubitz vom
vierten auf den ersten Platz und bleibt
damit die führende im Gesamtweltcup
wir bleiben noch beim Sport beim
Spitzensport für den jetzt auch ein
zweites corona-jahr zu Ende gegangen ist
mit all dem was das auch für Athleten an
Einschränkungen und Belastungen bedeutet
hinzu kommt dass ich jetzt die
Infektionsfälle mehreren und immer
häufiger Sportler vor Turnieren oder
Spielen ausfallen doch jenseits von
Corona gibt es noch andere Probleme die
den Sport und seine Leistungszentren
schon lange beschäftigen
letztlich geht es dabei um die Frage was
der Gesellschaft der Spitzensport mit
seinen Medaillen und Wettbewerben Wert
ist Melanie haackbericht
Spitzensport beginnt in den
Kinderschuhen beim
eisschnelllauf-training mit
Olympiasiegerin Daniela Anschütz Thoms
37 Jahre Erfahrung auf dem Eis heute
trainiert sie den Nachwuchs in Erfurt
findet und formt Talente im Ehrenamt
bleib mal richtig an der Linie mein Ziel
ist die Olympiade zu besuchen
meine Frau
Vorbilder als Ansporn sich hochkämpfen
dranbleiben für den langen Weg an die
Weltspitze brauche es noch mehr gerade
in den weniger populären Sportarten
findet an schützt Thomas man ist zwar
Olympiasieger ja das wird man immer
bleiben das ist ganz toll
aber wie wird das gefördert oder oder
geachtet oder entlohnt ja und das finde
ich ist heute noch weniger geworden die
Frage ist ja immer kann ich damit Geld
verdienen ja im Eisschnelllauf kann man
das also tatsächlich nur bedingt Patrick
Beckert ist die neue Olympia Hoffnung
hier eine der wenigen die Bedingungen am
Stützpunkt sind gut trotzdem hören viele
Leistungssportler nach der Schule auf
wir haben Tag bis zu sechs Stunden im
trainiert dann bleibt er nicht viel Zeit
für andere Dinge und das heißt
dementsprechend muss man aber irgendwo
halt Geld herbekommen um dann die
Sportart auch ausüben zu können Beckert
ist 31 und Sportsoldat bei der
Bundeswehr sie fördert Kader abhängig
von den Leistungen auf Zeit
danach beim DOSB arbeiten Sie an einer
leistungssportreform an Perspektiven
parallel zum Sport die Ausbildung zu
strecken das heißt die Ausbildung nicht
über drei Jahre sondern über fünf Jahre
dass der Athlet nur stundenweise
arbeiten muss die andere Sache ist die
dass man nach der Karriere sofort einen
Ausbildungsplatz bekommt aber so bezahlt
wird wie ein voller Job Basis des
Spitzensports ist die Vereinsarbeit die
Defizite hier liegen auch bei frank
Ulrich und dem neuen Sportausschuss im
Bundestag auf dem Tisch es ist Ehrenamt
und Ehrenamt sollte man nicht zu
kompliziert gestalten es soll das wer
viel viel mehr wertschätzen und sollte
Ihnen auch die bürokratischen Hirten
etwas nehmen und deswegen sollten wir
auf alle Fälle gerade das Ehrenamt noch
mal viel viel mehr stärken am
Olympiastützpunkt Oberhof wurde viel
investiert in Schanzen und Eiskanal gute
Bedingungen für Carsten Albert der hier
die Rennrodler die Nachwuchshoffnungen
trainiert Melli jawohl das besser er
kämpft um jedes Talent das gefunden ist
und das wird immer schwieriger zuletzt
durch Corona es gibt einen schlechten
bis gar keinen Sportunterricht die
Bewegungserfahrung der Kinder ist
deutlich schlechter das ist halt
wirklich schwierig Kinder auch zur
Bewegung zu animieren ganz oben sein
fängt ganz unten an kein Spitzensport
ohne Breitensport wenn deutsche Athleten
auch in Zukunft an der Weltspitze
mitmischen sollen
und jetzt zum Schluss wie immer sonntags
unser Ausblick auf die neue Woche im
neuen Jahr von Lara Wiedeking
[Musik]
am Montag werden in fünf Bundesländern
Schülerinnen und Schüler in den
Präsenzunterricht zurückkehren
Brandenburg hatte den Ferienbeginn im
Dezember vorgezogen um die Verbreitung
von Omikron einzudämmen auch hier wird
ab Montag wieder die Schule beginnen bei
einem Krisengipfel am Mittwoch wollen
die Kultusminister über weitere
Maßnahmen diskutieren
vor dem bund-ländergipfel wird sich die
FDP zu ihrem Dreikönigstreffen digital
zusammenfinden
einen Tag später geht auch die CSU in
winterklausur allerdings wie schon 2021
im Bundestag statt im bayerischen
Kloster Seeon
Angriff auf die Demokratie haben
US-Medien nach dem Sturm auf das Kapitol
vor einem Jahr getitelt fünf Menschen
kamen dabei ums Leben
doch die Demokratie schlägt auch zurück
so wurden erste Angreifer zur Haft
verurteilt hunderte Verfahren laufen
noch
und auch der Untersuchungsausschuss ist
längst nicht abgeschlossen die Rolle von
exos-präsident Trump beim Sturm auf das
Kapitol noch nicht geklärt
schon ab Sonntag wird in der
Elbphilharmonie in Hamburg fünfjähriges
gefeiert zum Auftakt der
Geburtstagswoche wird kennt Nagano die
Arche dirigieren am 11 Januar 2017 nach
fast zehn Jahren Bauzeit konnte die Elfi
endlich eingeweiht werden und hofft auf
noch viele weitere Jahre ausverkaufter
Konzertsäle
[Musik]
und noch der Blick aufs Wetter morgen
wechseln bewölkt mit vielen Schauern
längere trockene Abschnitte vor allem im
Osten und am Alpenrand starker im
Bergland stürmische Südwestwind
Höchstwerte 8 bis 14 Grad am Dienstag
viel Regen bei teils stürmischem Wind 6
bis 15 Grad ab Mittwoch deutlich kälter
mit Regen und Schneeschauern
das war es von uns zum Jahresauftakt
weiter geht es mit Inspector Barnaby um
0.30 gibt es dann die nächste heute
Express und uns morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]